he's special I know he's special I
raised him and now are returning to
where he belongs
the jungle duck rated PG this is not a
game the jungle is no longer safe for
you you're being hunted by a tiger town
and I got your attention now
how many lives is a man come worth tres
season
the Jungle Book pretty peachy are you
alone out here what are you doing so
deep in the jungle
don't you know what you are
I know
I know where you came from
poor sweet little cow
I'll keep you close
let go of your fear now
and tres
you
if you can't learn to run with the pack
one of these days you'll be someone's
dinner
McConnell but noticed as the strange
older today man is forbidden
unreal
the jungle is no longer safe for you
only man can protect you now
poor sweet little cow what are you doing
so deep in the jungle you were a man cub
who wants to live in a jungle how you
know that kid I got is my ears got is
only I can protect you
forget about your losingest rally
that's a song about the good life
he will stop at nothing to be as this
boring if anything happens to that kid I
will never forgive myself
come on Mowgli let's be on our way but
I'm helping blue get ready for
hibernation bears don't hibernate in a
jungle not full hibernation but i nap a
lot when to pain it's it--maybe liked 41
demons are don't get sandstone a mile
it's that I missed if my fight